El Nino it's Spanish for the boy but
it's also used to refer to a weather
phenomenon in the Pacific Ocean trade
winds usually blow east to west bringing
warm surface water with them and causing
South Asia and Australia's monsoon
season but during an El Nino year these
wind patterns weaken and that warm
surface water moves to the other side of
the ocean this brings all sorts of crazy
weather like drought in Australia storms
in coastal South America and heavy rain
in the set of the United States for the
northern states this could actually mean
a warmer than usual winter the last
intense El Nino happened in 1998 in
California and much of the South saw
devastating floods but forecasters
predict that this year's El Nino is
going to be the worst yet